All right, Aaron Tartakovsky,
thank you for being on the show.
Thank you very much.
And you said my last name perfectly,
which is not easy to do.
I've been rehearsing for quite some time,
as you know.
So, I'm very excited to talk about.
What are you doing with Epic Clean Tec?
It's probably one of the best names
for a startup that I've ever heard.
And from the few lines
that I read about the company,
I think it does justice
to how awesome what you're doing is.
But right before we get there,
I'd love to go back
and talk a little bit about your background
and where you came from.
Because you've had an interesting
mix of studying both at Tufts.
But then at Tufts University to APAC.
And now also an investor at Jay Ventures.
So, talk to me a little bit about
who you are.
And how you got to found a company
called Epic Clean Tec.
Yeah. Well, again, thank you for having me.
Look, you know my background.
It's not a straight line.
I went a lot of different places.
I think on paper,
what I'm doing now
doesn't make a lot of sense.
You know, I'm born and raised as
nice Jewish boy from San Francisco.
I went to school in Boston
And in Boston,
I got really involved in politics.
I got involved in politics
around the Middle East,
around US-Israel policy.
So I always knew
that I was going to eventually
go and spend more time in Israel.
Why by the way?
Well, you know, coming from San Francisco,
going to Boston.
Why do you get so passionate
and involved with politics there?
This is a long story.
It's not just about me.
This is more of a family story.
So my grandfather,
like a lot of people in Israel,
but also a lot of Jews
and all around the world.
We trace our roots to Poland.
And my grandfather as a young teenager
was involved in these
youth Zionist groups.
And he was the leader of the
youth Zionist group in his little shtetl
in the middle of nowhere, Poland.
And for him, you know,
it was always a dream.
One day to have
a modern day state of Israel.
And that's always been important to me.
Not just because it's what we read every day
in the Haggadah and everything else.
But to have,
in Israel is a miracle now.
And I always wanted
to be involved in that.
And when it comes to politics,
America is a special place
where we can get involved in politics.
We can make changes through politics.
Very special.
I have a father who is from his refusenik
from the Soviet Union.
Where the thought of going
and actually lobbying for change
with your elected officials
was something that was possible.
And I was very aware that
I had the special privilege.
And so I got involved in college.
That's something that I carried with me.
I studied history and Jewish studies.
So, again, on paper,
I probably should have become
Priester or Rabbi.
Neither of those things happened.
You settled for crazy entrepreneur.
I settle for crazy entrepreneur
who works with toilets for a living.
Yeah. So, a weird story.
That says it all.
So, Aaron, you find yourself in Tel Aviv.
You spend some time there.
And then you go to a AIPAC.
What do you do at AIPAC?
At AIPAC I worked in development.
So it was my job to raise money
and to educate everyone
on the issues of importance to us.
Issues like US-Israelis relationship.
Issues like collaboration on
not just military things,
but on medicine,
on technology and energy.
And then also
focusing on big world issues
like the Iran nuclear program.
So those were the things that I was
really focused on when I was at it.
Wow. Okay. And now,
So, now let's just jump forward
at what do you do with toilets?
Why are you so excited
and passionate about toilets?
Yeah, that's a good question.
So, at Epic Clean Tec,
what we're doing is
we are basically rethinking
how cities handle both their water
and their wastewater.
A lot of times we also
call wastewater sewage.
Right.
You know, when it comes to cities,
we've essentially been doing things
the same way for about 200 years.
Which is to say we have buildings
then into sewers along can
complicate underground networks
that off to central treatment sites.
Right.
And that approach has worked.
But we've essentially been doing things
the same way that all of our cities,
with more and more people
moving into cities.
About 70% of the world's population
living in cities by 2050.
We're putting more strain.
All of these pipes
and all these facilities
that were installed
30 to 100 years ago.
Right.
Actually we at Epic,
We got our roots with the
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation.
I was just about to ask
because I know that Bill and Melinda,
they work vehemently on this topic
of the better infrastructure for toilets, right?
Absolutely. Yeah.
So, the Gates Foundation,
they have something called
the Reinvent the toilet challenge.
And what that said was billions of people
around the world don't have access
to clean water, reliable sanitation.
We can't continue to just build things
the same way.
We have in building big,
complicated underground infrastructure.
How do we create new,
inexpensive aboveground solutions
that we can deploy quickly?
So our company, me, and my co-founder,
has start of all of this,
came out of the Gates Foundation.
Sort of designing interesting
toilet applications.
And by the way,
the real real genesis of the whole story
goes back to the sidewalks of Tel Aviv.
One of my co-founders Oded
was walking down the streets
of Tel Aviv with his little pug dog
named Powley.
And Powley did his business
on the sidewalk.
Oded was not paying attention,
didn't clean up after the dog.
Received a fine from a police officer
who saw him walking on his dog.
And then him being these
sort of quintessential
fiery tempered entrepreneur.
Rather than paying a fine
and moving on with his life,
decided that he was going to come up
with a new 21st century solution
to clean up after dogs.
So, of course, some Israeli
entrepreneur is going to do this.
So then they started working
with the Gates Foundation
designing toilets.
They were then presenting
at a conference here in California
where me and my father
were in the audience.
My father is an engineer.
Originally an engineer in
Soviet space program before he came here.
Wow.
He now designs building systems,
mechanical systems,
electrical systems, plumbing systems.
We said, can we take  what we were doing
with one toilet with the Gates Foundation
put it into an entire building.
And so what we do is, as I said,
normally a building big 40 storey high rise
in downtown LA, San Francisco,
Boston and Tel Aviv,
Everything all of the dirty water
goes from the building that into the sewer.
What we do is we install our system
into the basement of that building.
We do two things.
One is we pull all of the solids
out of the water.
All of the organic solids.
Things that we eat and go out of our body,
and we turn those into fertilizer.
So this is really amazing
Carbon rich fertilizer we've
been using in around cities.
The water we then treat
and put back into the buildings.
We actually help buildings reduce their
water needs by [--]
And I saw your face.
That's what we called the industry
the yuck factor that people are
uncomfortable with this idea.
So, one important thing is that right now
we only reuse water for non drinking.
So, for example for toilet flushing.
Oh, yeah.
I was assuming that you're also
trying to make it into a drinkable water?
On venture side,
scientifically, we can produce
any kind of water we want.
But by regulation
and as the reaction of you
and other people,
a lot of people like you,
now we're focused on just reusing water
for things, like I said,
toilet flushing, cooling towers,
which by the way, most of the water
in buildings is for that anyways.
So, obviously I'm making these faces,
but it is solving a huge, huge issue.
And I mean, the lack of accessibility
to drinkable water,
let alone, you know,
water for the toilets
is a huge problem.
And if you're able to to design buildings
that are allowing for that to happen.
By the way, how much potential
could be recycled from the water
that we use, let's say, on the average flush
from a number one or number two?
So, on average, with all the water
that a building produces,
all the dirty water that they create,
we can reuse anywhere
from 40 to 90% of it.
40 to 90%.
Which basically means that,
So, about like if we use
if we look at the consumption over a week,
we can basically narrow it down
to the consumption of two days
out of the week.
And that will give us the whole runway.
And then, what is that
gonna do to the world?
So let's look at the vision further ahead.
Let's say you were able to
implement this in every building
in New York
and every building in SF.
What impact?
And how does this then later on
impact the developing areas?
Or are you not concerned with that yet?
No, we absolutely are.
This is the solution that we're starting
in downtown San Francisco.
Because there's a lot of regulations
and incentives for it.
And it just goes kind of
the start of what will people,
We think is sort of gonna be
a revolution in how cities are designed.
In terms of their urban wastewater.
But a helpful analogy of how
to think about all of this.
It is decentralization.
So, you can look at a lot of different
industries that have moved away
from big centralized infrastructure
to decentralized.
So, one really good example
is telecommunications.
It used to be we used any poles
and wires to connect everything.
And then with the advent of cell phones,
everything became decentralized.
You look at the energy industry
where it we use to only be
focused on big plants,
coal plants, nuclear plants.
And then we started decentralizing.
We started creating wind farms.
And we started putting
solar panels on people's roofs.
We're doing that same decentralization.
But for the water wastewater world,
we're just about 15 years
behind the energy guys.
But that's exactly,
the way to think of what we're doing
is exactly what they did.
We're just doing it for
a completely different industry.
Right. And how do you get the water back up?
So if I'm on this on the second floor,
does a recycled water maintain on my floor?
Or is there a whole system that
transitions it throughout the building?
Yeah. So, the good thing is that pumps,
we don't even have to invent those.
We just use pumps that we can put
the water up however high we need.
So, we're talking now to
one projects in San Francisco.
That's 55 stories.
We're talking to one project in Seattle.
That's 90 stories.
So, we can get the water
wherever we need to get it.
Incredible. And does that require
the buildings to be
planned in advance for this?
Or can you also go into existing buildings
and make those modifications?
So, our focus is on new construction
Because it just makes sense.
Because we can do designing for that.
But in certain cases,
we actually can do retrofits.
And in fact, in September of 2019,
we did a retrofit into a 35 storey
high rise in San Francisco
called the Nema Building.
Which is right between
the Twitter headquarters
and the Uber headquarters.
That's our first deployment.
And that was a retrofit.
And I'll tell you
what it is a retrofit.
That means that those people
in this case,
so, it's 754 fully occupied apartments.
Which means we started
making adjustments to the pipes.
In the industry
we call that a hot tap.
Which means no matter what,
there's going to be stuff
coming through those pipes.
So we went in at three AM.
Which when we thought
there'd be the least amount
of flushes in that building.
And we kind of sat there
we're all that nervous
as we went up on a ladder
or an elevator ladder about 20 feet.
Removed a section of pipe.
Moves really quickly
and kind of were holding our breath.
And guess what?
No flushes.
We got away
without any single flushes
coming on us.
Which by the way,
when you worked in this industry.
You do what I do.
You know, sometimes I'm not
neatly dressed wearing a suit.
A lot of times we're getting
pretty, pretty dirty.
But that's what we gotta do.
That's what we gotta do
to try and build something different
and knew you've got to get dirty.
And that's an analogy.
I think it's a metaphor not just for us,
but for every new project.
Or every new venture.
Right. So, I mean,
what where does this headed?
So, give me sort of like, you know,
you're as a CEO and founder,
What is your timeline and
envisioning ahead?
What are the different
markets you're going after?
And when can we expect this to be sort
of a mainstream thing?
Where the average person realizes
that the water that they're using
in their toilet,
or in their water fountains,
for brushing their teeth,
is actually recycled water
from the building.
Yeah. Look you know, it's as I said,
it's starting in San Francisco.
So, we actually,
part of the benefit
of coming from politics
is we actually helped work
with a number of people
to make San Francisco
the first city in the entire country
to require that all new large buildings
have to have onsite
water recycling system.
Oh really.
similar legislation in California.
And by the way, look, you know,
we as a country in the United States,
we recycle maybe two or 3%
of all of the wastewater we produce.
You look at a country like Spain,
they're number two in the world
at around 34 to 35%.
Israel is closer to 90%.
So Israel basically sets the bar
for what we,
how we should be thinking about water.
Israel recycles 90% of its water?
It recycles 90% all of its wastewater
that they produce. Yeah.
Oh, my. Oh, I had no idea. Wow.
Yeah.
Israel is a world leader
when it comes to water
and water innovation.
I mean, it kind of makes sense.
We have to have water in the desert
and we only have this tiny Kinneret.
Which one year is grade one.
New year it's a dried up.
So, we really can't take
too many risks.
I mean, did you think you would get
into this business?
You know, as you in AIPAC,
I mean, as you're going through your life.
Did you realize that  you wanted
to build a company that does,
that's such a major impact,
and a big social impact, actually?
I know ever since I was young,
I always knew that I wanted
to be involved in things,
that we're having a very
positive impact on the world.
Yeah.
I didn't know what that looked like yet.
Some people know from day one,
I want to be a doctor.
I want to be a pilot.
I want to do this.
I want to to that.
I didn't know what the hell I want to do.
I thought I was gonna go to law school.
I thought I was gonna try this.
At one point, I wanted to be a chef.
I wanted to be vegetarian.
But what I knew
sort of the one guiding light for me
was that I wanted to do something
that was gonna have a big impact on the world.
And frankly, I couldn't see myself
doing anything that wasn't
sort of impact focused.
And so for me,
I didn't know much about water.
I don't know much about the environment.
I don't know much about climate change
or all these big sort of sustainability issues.
But I knew that I could learn.
I'm a quick learner.
And I knew that if I was doing something
that I cared about,
I would be able to add in all
the other important stuff.
I would be able to add in the technical
skills and everything else.
And that's what happened with Epic.
Before we officially farmed out big.
I spent about six months
just talking to everyone
that he had not even sort
of a very basic connection
to what we were doing.
I spoke with building developers,
architects, engineers.
I spoke with scientists.
I spoke with professors.
I went to farmer's markets
and went up to the people and said,
"Hey, would you use treated
human waste on your crops?"
And I just talked to everyone
to just find out what are the problems?
What are the red flags?
What are the things that
we should be looking out for?
And we just learned.
We just learned.
And, you know, there's an element of
we got lucky that five years ago,
if you ask someone,
"Can we recycle waste water on buildings?"
They would say, "I don't know."
And now we have laws in the books
in San Francisco and in California
that make it possible.
So, you know, I think
to me, when I talk to other sort of people
thinking about going into starting ventures
and becoming entrepreneurs,
you don't need to know all the answers.
You just need to be someone who's
comfortable with the fact
that you're not going to know
all the answers one time.
And how many other players
are in this market right now
that are sort of working on
similar problems like you are?
When it comes to our competitive landscape,
I can name all of those people
on one hand.
Wow. Okay.
So, definitely, I mean,
when you get to a point where a nation
or a large city decided that it's important enough
to make a law out of this.
And for any new construction.
And you're only one of a few that are
able to do this, I think.
I think you're in a pretty good position.
Aaron, what other things
around the world
now that you're,
you have experience in looking at these
different day to day things that we might
take for granted.
I never even thought about the water
that we're wasting through our toilet system.
What other things can we be hopeful
looking forward that we can
revolutionize and make
a positive impact on the world?
Look, I'll tell you one thing
I'm excited about is that,
before I started Epic,
I ran a business development marketing
for a large engineering company.
My father's company.
And one of the things that I did
was I ran the internship program.
Which means I reviewed
every single application that came in.
And I'll tell you the one
almost every single application.
One thing in common is that
they wanted to be part of a company
that was focused on sustainable design.
That was focused on creating healthier,
greener and more sustainable buildings.
And so, when I look at that,
that to me tells me that
there's a whole new generation
of engineers who, frankly,
build the world that are focused
not just on building things.
But on building things better
and creating a better future.
So, when I look at that,
I'm not just looking at my industry.
I'm looking at every single industry.
And this new wave of the top engineers
who this is how they're being
trained and this is how they think.
I'm really optimistic.
You know, I think when people you know,
when you think about something
like climate change,
you know, people kind of always
want to find what's the solution.
Where should we be investing
billions of dollars?
And you know, what I believe is
there is no one silver bullet.
But instead, we need to use
what we call silver buckshot.
We need to do a ton of different solutions
all at the same time.
And that's a quote, by the way,
borrowed from Bill McKibben,
who's a very well-known climate activist.
And, you know, I think really,
as I mentioned, when we only recycle
3% of the wastewater in this country,
that means we have a long way to innovate.
And which means it's exciting.
There's so many different things we can do.
That's what keeps us excited that I think.
Definitely.
And is the business of doing something
like Epic clean tech,
You know I'm coming from a much more
science oriented place.
And I'm thinking immediately.
Okay, I see you raise your seed,
and then you build your MVP, and then
you raise a huge institutional around.
And you grow it and you scale it up.
Is that a similar model to running
a startup in the space that you're at?
Or is it much more incremental
and less of a hockey stick trajectory?
Yeah. So, I look at,
the basic similarities are there.
You need grit.
You need to be able to deal with failure
on many different fronts.
Both with the product
as well as you're
talking investors and customers.
But it is a different timeline for sure.
Because the whole move
to break things and move fast,
that whole methodology.
It's not necessarily translatable
to when you're dealing with something
like water where public health is
You know, that there's the
if you mess up,
you're going to kill someone.
Or you're going to get someone sick.
So we can't take quite the same risks.
Plus, we're working in one
of the most highly regulated
and oldest industries out there.
Whereas software is still
in many ways it's still the Wild West
where we're reinventing new things
and thinking of new things.
And software is eating the world, right?
It's nobody.
It's a different approach.
And in many cases,
we're more similar to kind of
the Uber model of regulatory hacking.
Where it's not just new technology,
but you have to figure out how to work
with an existing power structures
of cities and with industries.
And Uber stays with transportation,
which you only have to read about
the stories about the taxi unions.
And that whole industry
was very against this.
And by the way, take it back even further.
You know, when the first trolley cars
came to San Francisco,
you know who fought them?
Who?
All the guys who drove the horse
and buggy riders and 12 guys.
Well, these trolley cars are
going to put us out of business.
This is what happens.
Every single generation finds
the new innovation that's going
to put them out of business.
And but for us, it's different.
Because we're not going to put water
in wastewater plants out of business.
We're actually finding
a way to work with them.
So, we work really closely
with the utility here in San Francisco.
So, you know, the short answer is
our stuff is more expensive.
So, it's and it's a big physical heavy
we're talking about thousand pounds
of metalled steel and wires.
And so, it's different.
We don't iterate as quickly.
But all of the basic framework
of how to build something new is there.
Which is that you're gonna find our position.
You're gonna have to get in,
in our case, literally very dirty.
But the basic tool kit is the same.
I love it. Aaron, right before we leave,
I have to ask you
the most important question.
Three words that best describe you.
I'm going to flip it and I'm going to say
three words that my mom would use
to describe me.
That is Number One Son.
And I'm saying that just in case either
my older brothers out emerged
or Joseph are listening,
that I now put on the public record
that I'm most favorite son.
So there you go.
I love it. Number one son.
I love it.
Aaron, thank you very much.
Toda raba.
And I mean, it just sounds incredible.
I can't wait to move into
a building that has this.
And I can proudly say that
I know one of the pioneers of this
Who are making a positive impact
on the world.
And it's really fascinating.
Thank you.
You ever want to tour?
You let me know.
I just need a couple of extra clothes to
take with me, and I'm happy to join in.
We got that. Don't worry.
Toda raba.
Thank you very much.
Have a great rest of the day.
Bye bye.